COMING TODAY WHAT A NICE BIG
SHOWING --
WELCOME TO SENATE AS FIRST
COMMITTEE --
BILL HEARING.
THIS THE AFTERNOON WE HAVE ONE
BILL ON THE AGENDA SB.
ONE TWENTY SIX I AM THE AUTHOR
THE BILL ALONG WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER O'DONNELL --
BUT FIRST WE NEED TO ADOPT THAT
THE COMMITTEE RULES ALL MEMBERS
HAVE BEEN PROVIDED WITH A COPY
THE RULES MEMBERS AS ANYONE HAVE
ANY QUESTION ABOUT THE RULES
[inaudible]
OKAY.
MANAGE SECRETARY YES I'LL MAKE
THE MOTION THANK YOU SIR THERE'S
A MOTION.
I'M SORRY WE ARE GOING TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM FIRST.
SO EXCITED I AM.
HERE LEE THEY HERE WILL PRESENT
WELL CARED CHANGE.
CHAIN HERE DO ASAL GLAZER YEAH
PLEASER HERE MCGUIRE PAN.
HAND HERE.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU QUORUM HAS
BEEN ESTABLISHED NOW IF THERE
ARE NO QUESTIONS ABOUT THE RULES
WE WILL VOTE ON THE RULES.
MADAM SECRETARY IF YOU'LL PLEASE
RETURN OUR CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
LEYVA.
I BELIEVE AYE WILK WILL I CHANGE.
CHANGE BY THE RUSSELL GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE PAN.
PAN AYE.
WE WILL LEAVE IT ON CALL SO THAT
OTHER MEMBERS MAY HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE THE RIGHT
NOW I'M GOING TO TURN THE GAVEL
OVER TO YOU MISTER VICE CHAIR.
SO THAT WE CAN PRESENT.
WELL I WILL START AND HOPEFULLY --
O'DONNELL WILL.
GOOD GOOD GOOD GOOD TO SEE YOU.
I LOVE THESE CHAIRS ON OF THE
KIND OF EXISTING [inaudible]
THE SENIOR.
WE CAN A WE'RE GONNA HEAR SB ONE
TWENTY SIX SAYS CENTER LOS
LEAVING YOU MAY PROCEED THANK
YOU SENATOR WILK MISTER VICE
CHAIR.
I WOULD FIRST LIKE TO BEGIN BY
THANKING COMMITTEE STAFF AND ALL
STAKEHOLDERS HAVE COME TOGETHER
ON THIS MEASURE.
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
AND THEY CHARTER SCHOOL
TRANSPARENCY ISSUES.
MEMBERS THIS MAYES REFLECTS OUR
BICAMERAL RESPONSE TO THE
GOVERNOR'S CALL FOR ACTION.
THE CREATION OF CHARTER SCHOOLS
WAS INTENDED TO SUPPORT LOCALLY
DRIVEN EXPERIMENTATION TO
PRODUCE BETTER ACADEMIC RESULTS
THAT COULD BE EXPANDED AND THEN
COULD BE EXPANDED TO ALL
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS.
FULL CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE UNIQUE
IN MANY WAYS THEIR PUBLICLY
FUNDED AND YET THEY LACK THE
SAME TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY REQUIREMENTS THE
GOVERNOR OTHER PUBLICLY FUNDED.
INSTITUTIONS THIS BILL ENSURES
THAT CHARTER SCHOOLS WILL COMPLY
WITH THE SAME TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY LAWS THAT ALL OF
OUR OTHER PUBLIC SCHOOLS
CURRENTLY FOLLOW.
CHARTER SCHOOL GOVERNING BOARDS
WERE REQUIRED TO COMPLY WITH THE
SAME OPEN MEETING CONFLICT OF
INTEREST AND DISCLOSURE LAWS AS
TRADITIONAL PUBLIC SCHOOL BOARDS.
THIS BILL WILL ALSO ENSURE THAT
MEMBERS OF CHARTER SCHOOL
GOVERNING BOARDS ANNOT USE
THEIR POSITIONS FOR PERSONAL OR
POLITICAL GAIN. FOR SEVERAL
YEARS THE LEGISLATURE HAS
ATTEMPTED TO BRING CLARITY TO
THIS ISSUE.
FORTUNATELY OUR ATTORNEY GENERAL
RECENTLY PUBLISHED AN OPINION
CLEARLY STATING THAT YES THESE
GOOD GOVERNMENT LAWS DO APPLY TO
CHARTER SCHOOL GOVERNING BOARDS.
FOR THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OPINION PROVIDES MUCH NEEDED
CLARITY ON WHETHER OR NOT THESE
LAWS APPLY TO CHARTER SCHOOL
GOVERNING BOARDS.
THE OPINION IS NOT LEGALLY
BINDING.
ABSENT THE MEASURE BEFORE YOU
TODAY WHICH CODIFIES ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OPINIONS DISPUTE
DISPUTES WILL CONTINUE TO HAPPEN
ACROSS THE STATE OVER HOW THESE
LAWS APPLY TO CHARTER SCHOOLS.
MEMBERS THIS IS A FAIR DEAL AND
A GREAT OPPORTUNITY TO SOLVE A
LONG STANDING PROBLEM TO BENEFIT
TO THE BENEFIT OF CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS AND COMMUNITIES.
THIS BILL SUPPORTED BY TEACHERS
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS LABOR AND
CIVIL RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS. TO
KNOW MORE SPECIFICALLY THE CAL
CSUS MAJOR AND A CALIFORNIA
CHARTER SCHOOL ASSOCIATION IS
NEUTRAL.
I WILL NOW TURN OVER TO A
SOMEONE RIGHT DONALD FOR HIS
REMARKS.
THANK YOU.
MY HONOR.
YOU ARE HIGH AND OKAY THANK YOU.
I AM PLEASED TO BE A JOINT
AUTHOR OF THIS IMPORTANT BILL.
THIS IS A GOOD GOVERNMENT BILL
IT APPLIES GOOD GOVERNMENT LOSS
TO CHARTER SCHOOL OPERATIONS.
THIS BILL ENSURES THAT
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS ARE LEARNING
CENTERS NOT PROFIT CENTERS.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO ENSURE THE
USE OF OUR PRECIOUS FEW PUBLIC
SCHOOL DOLLARS ARE SUBJECT TO
TRANSPARENCY.
COMMON ETHICAL PRACTICES AND
GOOD GOVERNMENT LAW THAT IS
APPLIED TO TWO OTHER
GOVERNMENTAL OPERATIONS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY GENERAL
HAS VERY RECENTLY VERY RECENTLY
OPINED THAT THESE LAWS DO APPLY
THE CHARTER SCHOOLS BUT THIS
BILL PROVIDES ADDED CARITY.
THIS BILL PROTECTS PRESAGE AT
PRECIOUS EDUCATION DOLLARS WHICH
SHOULD BE USED FOR STUDENTS IN
SCHOOLS NOT TO LINE THE POCKETS
OF CHARTER SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS.
THE LIST OF CHARTER SCHOOLS WITH
THE HISTORY OF FISCAL
MISMANAGEMENT AS LONG CELERITY
MAGNOLIA AND TRI VALLEY ARE SOME
OF THOSE.
UNTIL NOW THESE SCHOOLS HAVE
RECEIVED SUCH A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNTS OF PUBLIC MONEY BUT NO
ACCOUNTABILITY AND IN FACT HAVE
ARGUED THAT CONFLICT OF INTEREST
OR TRANSPARENCY LAWS DO NOT
APPLY TO THEM.
WE SEEK TO CHANGES TODAY.
LOCALLY ELECTED SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBERS HAVE BEEN SUBJECT TO
TRANSPARENCY AND ETHICAL
STANDARDS FOR YEARS SO TOO
SHOULD CHARTER SCHOOL OPERATIONS.
ARE -- I
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS
CRITICAL MASS OUR SCHOOLS AND
OUR PUBLIC DOLLARS THANK YOU.
HERE IN SUPPORT IS SETH BROWN
BRAMBLE SORRY FIFTH AND WE HAVE
A CTA CARLOS MACHADO ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION AND CARLOS MARQUEZ.
ON BEHALF OF CSSA.
MISTER CHAIR AND SENATOR STUFF
BRAMBLE HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
PLEASE.
PART SENATE BILL ONE TWO SIX AS
A SIMILAR LEYVA MENTION CHARTER
SCHOOLS WERE ESTABLISHED WITH
THE PROMISE WILL GIVE YOU THE
FREEDOM TO INNOVATE.
YOU'LL SHOW US RESULTS LIKE
LIGHTHOUSES THESE WERE PLACE
WHERE YOU COULD DO SOMETHING A
LITTLE DIFFERENT.
AND MAYBE WERE LEARN SOMETHING
FROM WHAT WAS OCCURRING IN
APPLIED ACROSS THE ENTIRE SYSTEM
OF PUBLIC EDUCATION I WAS.
EXCITED IN A MEETING OF THE
LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION SEVERAL
YEARS AGO TO HEAR FROM THE
DIRECTOR OF THE CHARTER SCHOOL
DIVISION IN OAKLAND UNIFIED.
ABOUT THE SYSTEM THAT THEY CALL
KNOWLEDGE TRANSFER WITH THE
PRINCIPLES THAT CHARTERS AND THE
PRINCIPLES THAT --
NEIGHBORHOOD PUBLIC SCHOOLS WILL
COME TOGETHER AND SHARE LESSONS
LEARNED AND THAT'S WHAT WAS
INTENDED HERE BEST PRACTICES.
BUT THE PEOPLE CANNOT LEARN FROM
THIS INNOVATION IF THE PEOPLE'S
BUSINESS IS BEING CONDUCTED IN
CHARTER SCHOOLS --
WAS NOT ABOUT US THE PUBLIC
YIELDING CONTROL TO THE AGENCIES
THAT SERVE US.
WE'D NEVER INTENDED FOR CHARTER
SCHOOLS STONE RETAINING CONTROL.
AND ON THING INFORMED HAVING
SECRET AND PRIVATE MEETINGS
ABOUT HOW TAX DOLLARS ARE BEING
SPENT IS NOT INNOVATION THAT
DOES NOT BENEFIT THE SYSTEM AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER O'DONNELL
MENTIONED IT'S RESULT IN A
NUMBER OF HORROR STORIES.
UNHAPPY TO PROVIDE SPECIFIC
DETAILS AND EXAMPLES OF THE
COMMITTEE REQUESTS.
ABOUT WHAT THIS BILL IS SAYING
THE CHARTER SCHOOLS IS DO WHAT
YOU WANT BUT DO IT OUT IN THE
OPEN WHERE EVERYONE CAN SEE
TRULY WHAT THIS BILL IS SAYING
TO CHARTER SCHOOLS IS DREAM BIG
AND THINK OUTSIDE THE BOX.
BUT DON'T ABUSE THE PUBLIC TRUST
AND SPEND THAT MONEY ON OUR
STUDENTS PUBLIC EDUCATION MUST
BE ABOUT KIDS NOT PROFITS WE
URGE YOUR SUPPORT [inaudible]
IF YOU.
GET AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CARLOS
MACHADO WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL BOARDS ASSOCIATION HERE
IN SUPPORT OF SB.
ONE TWENTY SIX SB ONE TWENTY SIX
IS CONSISTENT WITH A
RECOMMENDATION THAT THE A TASK
FORCE THE CALIFORNIA ON SCHOOL
BOARDS ASSOCIATION HAD.
ISSUED A JUST RECENTLY ARE THIS
IS THE FIRST RECOGNITION THAT
REPORT THAT.
THE STATUTES APPLY TO CHARTER
SCHOOL BOARDS --
SB ONE TWENTY SIX CLARIFIES THAT
COMPETITION INNOVATION SHOULDN'T
OCCUR AT THE EXPENSE OF A
PARENTS STUDENTS PARENTS AND
STUDENTS PARTICIPATION --
FULLY WITHIN THE DECISIONS OF
THEIR CHARTER SCHOOLS.
MANY CHARTER SCHOOLS NOW ARE
COMPLYING WITH THE STATUS MANY
OF THEM HAVE AGREED --
TO CALLED AT A COMPLY WITH
INVOLUNTARILY.
THAT'S THROUGH --
THEIR WORK THAT THEY'VE DONE
WITH THEIR AUTHORIZED --
TO GREET --
TO AND FOUR SEN AND COMPLY WITH
THESE PROVISIONS --
AUTHORIZED ONLY DO SO MUCH IN
TERMS OF HAVING THE PETITIONER --
FOLLOWED THE STATUTES AND SB ONE
TWENTY SIX WILL HELP TO ENSURE
THAT THERE'S COMPLIANCE --
ACROSS THE BOARD AND THE LEVEL
PLAYING FIELD --
FOR THOSE PARENTS AND STUDENTS
ARE TENDING CHARTERS AT THE THIS
BILL WILL ENSURE THAT THEY HAVE
ACCESS TO MEETINGS THAT THEY
WILL HAVE ACCESS TO RECORDS --
AND THAT THE BOARD MEMBERS THAT
ARE MAKING DECISIONS REGARDING
THE CHARTER SCHOOL I DON'T HAVE
ANY COMPLEX --
SO -- S. S.
C. S. B. AS BEEN WORKING ON THIS
ISSUE FOR MANY YEARS --
WE'VE WORKED CLOSELY WITH OUR
STAKEHOLDERS AND ALSO AS HE SEE
A SAY IN THE PAST --
AND HAVING --
COMING VERY CLOSE TO REACHING --
AGREEMENTS IN THE PAST WERE
HAPPY TO SEE THAT WE'RE ALL THE
SAME TABLE AND WE CAN REACH
AGREEMENT ON THIS AND FOR THAT
REASON WE WOULD ASK THAT YOU
WOULD.
OF THOSE I ON THIS MEASURE THANK
YOU -- WELL
FIRST THAT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ACKNOWLEDGE THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE AND THE GOVERNOR'S TEAM --
THIS WAS OBVIOUSLY NOT AN EASY
PROCESS --
BUT WE ARE VERY PROUD --
TO TO BE ABLE TO TO SHARE WITH
YOU ALL TODAY THAT WE DO THINK --
THE LEGISLATION THAT YOU HAVE
BEFORE -- IS
A BALANCED APPROACH THAT BOTH
PRESERVES THE CORE I. TANAMI
INFLEXIBILITY GRANTED TO CHARTER
SCHOOLS UNDER THE CHARTER
SCHOOLS ACT.
THAT HAS ALLOWED US TO INNOVATE.
WITH OBVIOUSLY --
YOU KNOW HE REQUIREMENT TO
MANDATE THAT WE SHOULD BE DOING
OUR OUR BUSINESS OUR WORK IN THE
LIGHT OF DAY AND THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS DESN'T ALWAYS LEND
ITSELF TO GETTING EVERYTHING
THAT YOU'D LIKE --
WHICH IN PART IS WHY WERE OR NOT
DOT FULLY AECOM ONBOARD AS AS
THAT AS HAVING A SUPPORT
POSITION --
BUT WE DON'T SEE ANY MAJOR A
REASONS WHY THIS LEGISLATION
SHOULD MOVE FORWARD WERE
ABSOLUTELY.
EAGER -- TO
TO CODIFY WHAT MR MACHADO SHARED --
SO MANY OF OUR CHARTER SCHOOLS
ARE ALREADY PRACTICING EITHER.
VOLUNTARILY OR AS A RESULT OF
AGREEMENTS WITH THEIR AUTHORIZED
ERRORS.
AND WE HOPE THAT THAT CLARITY
AND AT MORE COLLABORATION AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL BETWEEN DISTRICTS
AND CHARTERS.
AND HOPEFULLY WILL WILL TAKE
THIS CASUAL OFF THE TABLE --
ARE FOR OPPONENTS.
TO YOU KNOW --
PERHAPS --
DE ESCALATE SOME OF THE RHETORIC
AROUND --
CHARTER SCHOOLS BEING --
THE FOR PROFIT CENTERS AND OUR
BOARD MEMBERS --
LOOKING TO GET INTO THIS AS THE
WORK OF PUBLIC EDUCATION TO LINE
THEIR POCKETS WEWE COULDN'T
AGREE WITH THOSE --
THOSE ASSERTIONS --
AND WE CAN DISAGREE WITH THOSE
ASSERTIONS MORE VEHEMENTLY SO --
HOPEFULLY AT SETTLING THIS AREA
AND LAW WILL WILL PUT THOSE --
ALSO IT'S TO BAD [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHERS SPEAKERS --
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TRISTEN BROWN OF THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS INSTRUCTS FOR THIS BILL
WE ALSO WOULD HOPE THAT IT DOES
SPECIFY THAT THIS IS DECLARATORY
OF EXISTING LAW JUST WE KNOW
THAT'S WHAT IT'S DOING WOULD BE
NICE FOR TO SAY THAT AS WELL.
BUT OTHERWISE --
VIRGIN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MICHAEL YOUNG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION ALSO
YOUR SUPPORT.
JEFF BACA REPRESENTING THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS IN SUPPORT.
CASEY CARLSON SPECIAL EDUCATION
TEACHER SANTA CRUZ --
EXPRESSING MY SUPPORT ALSO.
ELIZABETH ASK AVAIL AT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
BUSINESS OFFICIALS WERE NOT
FORMALLY LISTED ON THE ANALYSIS
ASSISTANCE APART BUT THIS WEEK
AND ARE COMMITTEE TOOK A SUPPORT
POSITION SOLD --
WE HAVE BEEN ADDED TO THE
COALITION LETTER WE APPRECIATE
CENTER LEYVA AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL TAKING AND LEADING ON
THIS ISSUE.
THANK YOU.
I THINK WE'RE GOOD NOW UNITED
TEACHERS LOS ANGELES IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
RICCO TAMAYO PRESIDENT OF THE
EARLY CHILDHOOD T. K. TWELVE
COUNSEL FOR THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS THE
COUNCIL AND ITS MEMBERS ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU THANK.
AMANDA DICKEY ON THE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
KATHY MAKE BAD REPRESENTED ACCEL
ALSO IN SUPPORT. FOR NAY BAYARDO
IS HERE YOU CALIFORNIA ALSO IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
HAIR CUT.
YEAH LOOKS GOOD.
STATE METICULOUSLY SIDE FIRST OF
TEACHERS ALSO IN SUPPORT.
NICK FROM WHERE WE HAVE THE SAN
FRANCISCO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
REGULAR REPRESENT A. B. C.
FEDERATION TEACHERS ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
WHERE CENTER OF THE SMALL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION SUPPORT?
BRUTALITY WITH THE NEWPORT MESA
FEDERATION TEACHERS IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
YEAH.
TINY GOLDEN A. B. C. FEDERATION
OF TEACHERS AND SUPPORT.
CAROLINE SMALL VICE PRESIDENT
APERI EDUCATORS HE UNITED
EDUCATORS AS SAN FRANCISCO IN
SUPPORT.
AMANDA TO PORAC HIGH SCHOOL
TEACHER IN BERKELEY AND MEMBER
OF BFT IN SUPPORT.
JEFFREY TO SECRETARY TREASURER
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND SUPPORT AND THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING THIS DEMOCRATIC
PROCESS TO BE SHOWN DURING OUR
MEET AND GREET LOBBY DAY.
I JUST WONDER ABOUT THAT.
PEOPLE ARE NOT TAKING TINY HERE
FOR THE BROADBAND MISSION
INDIANS I MEAN THAT NORFOLK NO
FORMAL POSITIONS OWN AT THE
MOMENT WE MIGHT HAVE SOME MORE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS --
IN THE FUTURE BUT FOR PURPOSES
OF TODAY WE REALLY WANTED TO
APPRECIATE TO EXPRESS OUR
APPRECIATION WITH RESPECT TO THE
TRIBAL RELATED --
PUBLIC RECORDS ACCESS PIECE OF
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
THANK YOU.
WHY I HAVE TO COMMEND YOU WELL I
DIDN'T SAY YOU HAD TO ME TO IT
BUT YOU ALL DID?
SO YOU.
KNOW I GUESS COULD SAY THEY'RE
OFTEN EDUCATION I DO HAVE A
NIECE AS SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
HE COME FORWARD.
THEY REALLY WERE YOU WANT TO SET
WELL [inaudible]
FRIENDS HERE.
CAROLYN --
HALLORAN WITH THE CHARTER
SCHOOLS DEVELOPMENT CENTER AND I
APOLOGIZE I GOT MY LETTER IN
LATE LAST NIGHT --
WE ARE NOT OPPOSED TO
TRANSPARENCY AYE WE ARE HOWEVER
OPPOSED TO A FEW PROVISIONS IN
THIS BILL THAT WE'VE DISCUSSED
BEFORE WHEN THEY WERE IN OTHER
MEASURES.
AND THIS BILL IS NOT THE SAME AS
THE CURRENT PROVISIONS THAT
APPLY TO TRADITIONAL DISTRICTS.
UNDER A COUPLE ITEMS AT ALL
POINT OUT --
FOR INSTANCE --
THE ISSUE AROUND WHETHER OR NOT.
I SAID ON A TRADITIONAL SCHOOL
<c.green>OARD AND WE ARE ALLOWED TO MEET</c>
WHEREVER IN OUR DISTRICT WE
WOULD LIKE TO MEET --
AND WE DO THAT BECAUSE WE THINK
THAT THAT INCREASES TRANSPARENCY
WE NEED AT OTHER SCHOOLS IN OUR
DISTRICT WE NEEDED OUR CITY HALL
WHERE --
IT'S AVAILABLE AND WE ALSO DON'T
HAVE TO DO IT TO A TRANSMISSION --
AND AND WE THINK THAT PUTTING
THOSE RESTRICTIONS ON CHARTER
SCHOOLS IS COUNTER INTUITIVE TO
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO HERE --
BY NOT ALLOWING CHARTER SCHOOLS
TO MEET AT SOME OF THEIR OTHER
SITES.
SO THAT'S ONE OF THE ISSUES WE
HAVE --
ANOTHER ISSUE --
IS THAT IF YOU'RE GOING TO STAB
THE BURDENS OF A PUBLIC AGENCY
ON CHARTER SCHOOLS IN PARTICULAR
THE COSTS OF THE TO A
TRANSMISSION THOSE SORTS OF
THINGS WE THINK THAT YOU SHOULD
BE LOOKING AT SOME OF THE
BENEFITS OF A PUBLIC AGENCY.
AND THAT WOULD IN PARTICULAR BE
THAT --
STATE MANDATED COST
REIMBURSEMENTS --
AND THE LA --
JUST PUT OUT A REPORT --
I THINK ON THE EIGHTEENTH OF THE
MONTH.
AND AND IT TALKS ABOUT ALL OF
THE COSTS THAT SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ARE ENTITLED TO THAT CHARTER
SCHOOLS ARE NOT ENTITLED TO
REIMBURSEMENT.
FOR SO SO THOSE THINGS WE THINK
OUGHT TO BE IN THERE FOR GOING
TO START GOING DOWN THE PATH OF
REALLY MAKING CHARTER SCHOOLS
PUBLIC AGENCIES.
AND LASTLY I THINK THAT --
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT TO THE
ANALYSIS.
THE IDEA THAT WE TALK ABOUT
CHARTER SCHOOLS ONLY HAVING --
BROWN ACT IN PLACE BECAUSE
THEY'RE AUTHORIZED YEARS IT WAS
PART OF THE ENFORCEMENT OF OFF
THE RISERS.
IS REALLY STRONG LANGUAGE I
WROTE A CHARTER IN TWO THOUSAND
AND FOUR AND I PUT THE BROWN ACT
IN THERE BECAUSE I THOUGHT THAT
THAT WAS THE RIGHT WAY TO DO
BUSINESS.
NO ONE FORCED ME TO DO THAT --
THERE IS NO ENFORCEMENT FROM OFF
THE RISERS SO I THINK THAT WE'RE
JUST NOT LOOKING AT THE WAY
CHARTER SCHOOLS REALLY OPERATE --
AND AND MAYBE TAKING SHOULD WE
TALK ABOUT THE THREE CHURCH
SCHOOLS YOU NOTED THAT HAD TO
ISSUES THERE'S A LOT OF CHARTER
SCHOOLS IN THE STATE AND THEY'RE
ALL.
DIFFERENT SO IT'S HARD TO APPLY
SOMETHING SO BROADLY AS TO THOSE
ARE CONCERNS THAT WE DO REMAIN
OPPOSED --
AND AGAIN NOT OPPOSED TO
TRANSPARENCY SO THAT'S A GOOD
FOLLOW UP QUESTION BECAUSE I I'M.
THE THIS CASE IS THAT THE SOME
WOMEN LAID LAID OUT ARE PRETTY
PRETTY WELL DOCUMENTED LA LA
TIMES MATERIAL HOW MANY CHARTER
SCHOOLS ARE THERE IN THE STATE
YOU KNOW.
I DON'T KNOW THE EXACT NUMBER
CHARTER SCHOOLS REPRESENT ABOUT
10% OF SCHOOL CHILDREN STATE.
THERE'S ABOUT. THIRTEEN HUNDRED
CHARTERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ROUGHLY THERE'S ABOUT
A THOUSAND SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
FAQ.
YEAH ANY OTHERS SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION.
CASEY NINE WE WILL PULL IT BACK --
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS
[inaudible]
MR GLAZER.
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIR --
WELL I WANT --
TO I WANT TO THANK --
THE AUTHORS THE GOVERNOR
STAKEHOLDERS FOR WORKING SO HARD
ON THIS ISSUE THAT HAS HAD A A
LITTLE BIT OF AN ESCALATED.
TIMELINE BUT SOMETIMES I WHEN
PEOPLE ARE IN AGREEMENT I
UNDERSTAND WHY THEY'D LIKE --
TO LIKE TO SETTLE IT AND I KNOW
THAT MEMBERS OF THE THE
COMMITTEE AND AND OTHERS ARE
AWARE THAT.
THIS IS AN AREA THAT I'VE HAD
LEGISLATION AND FOR FOR A FEW
YEARS CENTER ALLEN I BOTH.
AUTHORED LEGISLATION ON OPEN
MEETINGS AND DISCLOSURE CONFLICT
OF INTEREST RULES AND I AM
PLEASED TO SEE THAT.
THE LEGISLATION BEFORE US --
MAYORS IN SOME CASES IDENTICALLY
IT'S PROVISIONS AND I AND I
APPRECIATE THAT.
I WOULD NOTE THAT --
ON CONFLICT OF INTEREST THAT
THERE IS AN EXCEPTION THAT'S
PROVIDED IN THIS LEGISLATION --
ONE IN WHICH I SUPPORT.
WHICH IS ACCEPTING TEACHERS --
FROM THE CONFLICT OF INTEREST
RULES -- AS
LONG AS THEY DON'T HAVE A
FINANCIAL T!I.
AT TO THE CHARTER SCHOOL AND I
THINK THAT'S A THAT'S A GOOD
CHANGE OF CURRENT.
LAW IF YOU WILL --
BUT I THINK ONE THAT --
MAKES SENSE TO ME AND I'VE SEEN
OTHER OPPORTUNITIES IN THE STATE
WHERE WE'VE HAD TEACHERS AND
FACULTY.
ON BOARDS AND IT JUST MAKE SURE
THAT THEY DON'T PARTICIPATE IN
PLACES THAT WOULD CREATE THAT
CONFLICT OF INTEREST.
AND SO I'M I'M HAPPY TO SEE THAT
HERE.
I KNOW THAT THERE'S BEEN YOU
KNOW A LONG STANDING CONFLICTS
IN THE SPACE.
AND I KNOW THAT --
THAT WHAT WE HAVE BEFORE US AN
ATTEMPT TO ANSWER ALL THOSE
CONFLICTS.
I THINK TO GOVERNOR NEWSOME'S
CREDIT.
HE'S ASKED THE SUPERINTENDENT OF
SCHOOLS --
TO FORMULATED A TASK FORCE. TO
TRY TO WORK ON SOME OF THESE
OTHER AREAS AND I'M I'M HOPEFUL
THAT.
IT WILL BE IT WILL BE DONE IN A
CONSTRUCTIVE WAY.
I IN A TRANSPARENT WAY.
THERE'S A LOT OF SCABS OUT THERE.
AND SCARS.
AND US WHAT'S MY HOPE THAT THE
IN THE IN THE ACTION THAT WE
TAKE TODAY WHICH SHALL BE
SUPPORTIVE OF AND THE ACTIONS
THAT THE GOVERNOR IS INITIATED
REGARD THIS TASK FORCE.
THAT -- IN
THE COMING IN HERE AT LEAST THAT
WE CAN HAVE SOME PEACE IN THE
SPACE.
AND THAT WE'VE TAKEN CARE OF SO
IMMEDIATE ISSUES TODAY.
OVER IN A FEW DAYS WHEN IT
PASSES THE LEGISLATURE.
AND WILL HAVE FURTHER
DISCUSSIONS IN THE SENSITIVE
AREA --
WHERE THERE'S GOOD MEETING ON
ALL SIDES TO TRY TO DO WHAT'S
BEST FOR THE KIDS IN?
AS A WITNESS EARLIER HAD
MEASURES LIKE THIS DON'T GET
EVERYBODY EVERYTHING THAT THEY
WANT IT'S AN ATTEMPT TO TRY TO
FIND THAT BALANCE AND I CREDIT
THE AUTHORS IN THE GOVERNOR.
FOR ATTEMPTING TO DO THAT HERE.
AND IT'S MY HOPE THAT WE CAN
HAVE SOME RELATIVE PEACE IN THE
FACE FOR THE YEAR AHEAD AS WE
CONTINUE TO TALK AND WORK OUT
THESE ISSUES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER GLAZER CENTER
PAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND A TWO
ONE I THINK --
THE AUTHORS FOR BRING THIS --
BILL FORD AND ALSO ONE THING THE
GOVERNOR AND THE VERY
STAKEHOLDERS --
EL HAVING SERVED ON EDUCATION
COMMITTEE --
FOR I GUESS THE PAST FOUR YEARS --
THIS IS BEEN IMPEDED ISSUE WHERE
FRANKLY L. THERE WASN'T --
CLEAR LAW ABOUT --
CLOSURE AN OPEN MEETING AND I
THINK I I THINK MANY PEOPLE ARE
VERY UNCOMFORTABLE WITHOUT.
AND SO I AM PLEASED TO SEE THAT --
WE'VE FINALLY COME TO SOME
RESOLUTION ON THAT AND I ALSO
WANT THANKED ATTORNEY GENERAL.
FOR HIS OPINION AS WELL --
I WOULD ALSO MAKE NOTE AGAIN
LIKE MY GOOD FRIEND US ARE
GLAZER THAT --
THE SUPERINTENDENT OF THE
CONSTRUCTION I THINK IS
CONVENING A GROUP --
AND THE I DON'T BELIEVE THE
GOVERNOR IS ON BOARD WITH THAT
AS WELL SO I'M LOOKING FORWARD
TO THOSE KIND OF CONVERSATIONS --
WELL I CERTAINLY ALWAYS
APPRECIATE THAT PEOPLE COMING
BEFORE EDUCATION COMMITTEE TO
TALK ABOUT.
VARIOUS ISSUES I ALSO HOPE THAT
AS WE ARE ALL COMING TOGETHER TO
TRY.
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT WE CAN DO
THAT'S BEST FOR OUR STUDENTS
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
HERE -- FOR
THAT --
HOPEFULLY --
WE WE WANT TO BE SURE WE HAVE
THE COUNTY ENSURE THAT OUR
STUDENTS ARE GOING TO BE --
ALL OF OUR STUDENTS --
I HAVE A PARTICULAR INTEREST IN
SPECIAL ED STUDENTS ARE ARE WELL
SERVED.
BY OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM AND SO I
HOPE THAT WE CAN GIVE THIS --
A THIS.
BODY A CHANCE TO ALSO --
YOU KNOW WAY AND AND AND AND
WORK OUT SOME STUFF AND WORK OUT
SOME OF THE OTHER ISSUES AS WELL
AND LOOK FORWARD --
TO TO CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD
AND AND IN TERMS OF OF BEING
SURE THAT SO WE PUT OUR KIDS
FIRST AND AND WE CAN CONTINUE TO
AFFORD ON THAT SELF THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR FOR BRAIN THIS BILL
BEFORE US AND CERTAINLY I'D BE
HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL.
THE CENTER PANEL.
THIS -- UP
BY -- TWO
ONE TWO THANK THE GOVERNOR --
IN PARTICULAR FOR THE EXTRA PUSH
THAT HE PUT INTO THIS AND AND TO
TAKE IN A WORSE TODAY ANDA
CENTER LEYVA AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL.
FOR YOUR BEING A PART OF THAT
TEAM TO MOVE IT FORWARD AND JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT THE AREA OF WHY
I AM REALLY GLAD IN PARTICULAR
THAT THIS IS BEING MOVED.
IS -- I
THINK IT'S A IT PRESENTS THE
RIGHT STRENGTHENS THE RIGHT OF
PARENTS.
AND THEIR CHILDREN --
TO REPRESENT THEIR CHILDREN ON
WHATEVER ISSUES COME BEFORE THE
BOARDS AND I THINK THAT UNLESS
PARENTS ANNA.
FEEL THAT THEY HAVE ENOUGH
INFORMATION LAW AND THE ABILITY --
TO CHALLENGER ASK FOR THE
INFORMATION THEN IT HOLDS THEM
BACK UP AND I THINK UNLESS
PARENTS AND THE FAMILIES ARE
TRULY ENGAGED.
THAT PUBLIC EDUCATION IS NOT
GOING TO GET AS GREAT AS WE NEED
IT TO BE SO ANYTHING THAT
STRENGTHENS OUR RIGHTS I THINK
IS VERY IMPORTANT SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANYBODY ELSE ALL MAKE SOME
CLOSING COMMENTS AND BUT I I
AGREE YOU KNOW COULD JUST
EVERYBODY YOU KNOW BEING
INVOLVED I'VE SAT ON THIS
COMMITTEE FOR THE LAST TWO YEARS
ALONG WITH CENTER PANNING GLAZER
AND AND CIVIC CENTER LEYVA AND
WE'VE HAD SOME KNOCK DOWN.
DRAG OUTS AND THERE'S A LOT OF
DISTRUST ON BOTH SIDES WHICH I
THINK IS BEEN UNFORTUNATE
BECAUSE SHOULD BE ABOUT WHAT'S
IN THE BEST INTEREST --
EVER CHILDREN I DO LIKE THE THE
ACCOUNTABILITY THAT I ALSO AGREE
WITH SOME OF THE COMMENTS MADE
BY THE BY THE OPPOSITION I
UNDERSTAND THAT THAT.
WERE PLAN I CAN BE ABLE TO GET
ANY OF THOSE ISSUES INTO THIS
PARTICULAR BILL BECAUSE
NEGOTIATED AS DELEGATE AND AS
BALANCED BUT I HOPE THAT WE DO
COULD I GO TAKE A BITE AT THE
APPLE AT A LATER DATE ON ON SOME
OF THOSE SO --
WITH THAT NO OTHER COMMENTS SO
I'LL Là YOU TO CLOSE MADAM
CHAIR.
THE VICE CHAIR BY I JUST WANT TO
RECOGNIZE THE WORK THATYOU
SENATOR GLAZER IN CENTER ALLEN
HAVE DONE ON IN THIS AREA IN THE
LAST COUPLE OF YEARS.
AND I THINK WE'RE JUST TO A
DIFFERENT AND A UNIQUE MOMENT
WHERE WE HAVE A GOVERNOR WHO --
AGREES WITH SOME OF THINGS
YOU'VE WORKED ON AND WANTS TO
GET THIS PROCESS STARTED I WOULD
SAY I REALLY APPRECIATE THAT
THAT WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
START THE YEAR OFF MAYBE ON A
BETTER FOOT --
THAN IN THE PAST AND I WOULD SAY
IS SOMEONE WHO NEGOTIATED
CONTRACTS FOR MORE THAN A DECADE
IF EVERYBODY WALKS AWAY A LITTLE
BIT HAPPY OR A LITTLE BIT
UNHAPPY.
THAT WE DID A GOOD JOB WE DIDN'T
PICK WINNERS AND LOSERS AND I
LOOK AT THIS BILL IN THAT LIGHT.
AND THE TASK FORCE CAME UP A
COUPLE TIMES WE I DO NOT KNOW
ANYTHING ABOUT THAT HOUSE
FORCING TO MUCH INFORMATION.
WHAT I'VE BEEN TOLD IS IT WILL
FOCUS ON THE FISCAL IMPACT OF
CHARTER SCHOOL SO I TO WAIT TO
SEE?
HOW THAT PLAYS OUT BUT I THINK
YOU ALL FOR YOUR COMMENTS AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE?
TOMORROW DONALD JUST ECHO THE
SENATORS COMMONSENSE FOR THE
MOTION FROM DOCTOR PAN.
ITEM ONE SB ONE TWENTY SIX THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE FLOOR
AT LEYVA.
LEA THE I WILL I WILL I CHANGE.
CHIANG I'D TO WRESTLE.
I WOULD ALSO I'D GLAZER GLAZER
AYE MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE PAN.
PAN AYE.
SERVING REGULATIONS THE BILL'S
OUTING GOES DIRECTLY TO THE
SENATE FLOOR [inaudible]
YEAH.
I NEED I NEED AND REQUIRED TO DO
THAT SHE HASN'T TAKEN A YEAR
SOME.
WE NEED TO HAVE THE MATTER ON ON
THE RULES.
WE HAVE OTHER RULES ON CALL
SENATOR ALSO.
AND WE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
I HAVE FIVE ZERO WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I
WRESTLE.
RUSSELL I WIRE TO WIRE. SEVEN
SEVEN OH AND THAT IS OUT THANK
YOU EVERYONE VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE.
WE ARE ADJOURNED